[Music]
[Applause]
your genome is probably the single most
identifying unique thing about you the
goal of personalized medicine is about
gathering as much data as we can on
people to help us understand them better
in the research study through the
Colorado Center for personalized
medicine we're trying to leverage those
differences in our discoveries for each
patient who undergoes genotyping we get
about 2.1 million pieces of genetic data
what we need is the computational
resources to make sure that we will
never run out of storage space or that
we will never pay for storage space that
were not using underlying all of those
challenges are the questions of security
it needs to be stored somewhere that is
typical client even if it's
de-identified and our solution was to
move that data onto Google cloud
platform and gave us a way that was cost
effective and highly scalable and if
that was all it had given us we would
have been perfectly pleased what we're
finding is that that partnership is
enabling us to drive to the next level
of innovation and advanced analytics
Google bigquery as a data warehouse
that's our beating heart we gather data
from lots of different places we have to
match up patient records that activity
took about eight hours to run weari
implemented that logic in Google
bigquery and there finishes now in about
15 minutes through personalized medicine
we can give doctors tools to make the
best diagnosis and treatment decisions
with Google cloud platform we are
chasing down every opportunity to
improve human health by bringing this
data together and analyzing it in ways
that have never been analyzed before
[Music]